yeah a lot of bottles of champagne in
there first question in the middle on
for Coach congratulations Ryan Liang
Associated Press broadcasting there was
so much that happened between last
year's offseason and where you're
sitting at right now at this podium he
just talked about what it means to have
gone through all that becoming a
first-year head coach and after all the
changes in the offseason getting quiet
Leonard culminating in the city's a city
and the first championship for Toronto I
mean yeah it was a it was a it was a
heck of a twelve-months and I don't know
I just try to take things as they come
you know I didn't look too far ahead
obviously when we we made some additions
to the team you know we thought we could
be good but we have no idea what the
health status was and all those things
and again you just you just got to go
take the guys you got and go play and
manage it the best you can and then and
then look at the opponents and and try
to figure out a way to beat them and it
was it was a great group though they
really played together I thought they
really fought hard they were tough
minded they didn't seem like this was
wearing on them at all two months of
playoff basketball they never seemed
tired to me mentally they they kept
wanting the film sessions they kept
wanting to walk through things they kept
wanting to keep learning and improving
and I think that was a big key cuz we
had to do that in the playoff run
because we really hadn't had all that
much time together Steve on the right
side of the fourth row Steve Ashburn or
nba.com on every Eastern Conference team
that began the season aspiring to get to
the finals knew there was a good chance
that they would run into the Golden
State Warriors how much does it add to
what you guys have accomplished they you
beat a team that will be considered one
of the greatest in league history well I
mean you're first of all you're right I
think I think you thought get through
the East and the chances were you were
going to be playing
in Golden State I mean I probably stayed
up late and watch Golden State more than
anybody just for the heck of it right
just to see what they were doing and and
all that kind of stuff yeah I don't know
it means a lot for our city and our and
in the country you know and for these
players staff you know an incredible
group of people my assistant coaches and
the support staff and I don't I don't
know if it would have met any more any
less work to be honest with you you get
the win and you're just happy you got it
and and celebrate that fact the the
attrition in their team the injuries and
the fact that they were still in it
write up the stuff shot at the end I
mean there's a dad to the respect that
that people in the league would have for
a team like that a hundred percent that
was that was hard on them right I think
I think they had a rough year injury
wise in and they kept you know they kept
playing they got through some playoff
rounds and you know guys in and out and
obviously a lot of things a lot of a lot
of bad breaks and the finals to be
honest and um you know like us they kept
on playing you know we just got to keep
on play-doh matter who was out there and
and I think they were super intense high
level games and both teams desperately
trying to win and you know I have a
tremendous amount of respect for coach
Kerr and his staff and their players for
sure Tim last row in the back neck Tim
Reynolds with the AP congratulations of
course I know you are your least
favorite topic so I'm probably gonna
regret asking this question but what do
you think your story says as far as a
guy who played mid-major
a guy who had to go to Britain and a guy
that had to win a couple titles in the G
League where you got that phone call to
come talk about offense and the story
you were telling earlier yesterday or
today or something they all blend in now
what do you think your story is going to
mean to the coach who doesn't think he's
ever gonna get the shot well I would
hope it inspires some some people that
are in those situations to to keep
working you know I always say that all
those jobs meant the world to me
the time right when I went in with
Birmingham in 96 went in with Rio Grande
Valley whatever year that was and and
those those games and and jobs meant the
world to me and I loved all those jobs
and I think he can't do you're great you
can't do very good work if you don't
love what you're doing and I just I
don't know and I never really got
discouraged I didn't really care at the
level I was coaching that I was just
trying to learn and get better that's it
coach thank you very much thank you